du talent et du tempérament je suis là
philippe et le champion du monde que le
cyclisme français attendait depuis 23
ans un garçon qui ne cache ni son jeu ni
ses émotions
c'est le rêve de ma carrière
julian alaphilippe a construit son rêve
patiemment attendant l'ultime ascension
pour fausser compagnie au peloton est à
l'affût du portant sur l'accélération
maintenant poubelle s'est soudé il est
sorti river sortir et partie lancée le
français fait défiler les paysages
italiens à vitesse grand v 11 km en
solitaire à grimacer à se retourner mais
sans se faire attraper
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée champion du
monde à 28 ans après une année
douloureuse marquée par le décès de son
papa
ça a été difficile pour tout le monde je
pense que voilà c'est une récompense
pour moi mais pour l'équipe de france
pour le cyclisme si en général et moi
j'ai pas de mots en fait je suis et je
réalise pas trop encore pendant un an
julian alaphilippe portera ce maillot
arc en ciel comme un rayon de soleil
après la pluie
[Musique]